Maria Bartiromo had the governor on I
think this is yesterday and they talked
a bit about what's going on with the
campaign
you've done a great job pushing back
again
we know that
going on with your campaign there was a
lot of optimism about you running for
president earlier in the year but here's
this weekend's headline from the
Politico Playbook Failure to Launch
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis campaign
to topple Donald Trump has stalled we
are way behind says a top DeSantis Pac
official sounding the alarm what
happened
oh Maria these are narratives the media
does not want me to be the nominee I
think that's very very clear why because
they know I'll beat Biden but even more
importantly they know I will actually
deliver on all these things
so Andrew I I actually oh sorry uh
Spencer I actually agree with the
senatus there and I think it's almost
sort of silly for Bartiromo to quote
Politico when we know they're an
activist organization not a journalistic
outfit uh but the point is he should be
probably doing that on more combative
Television right yeah you know it gives
me no pleasure to say this because I uh
on balance would prefer to see DeSantis
win the nomination
um but there's a likability problem
there and I didn't quite expect it I
think that I and maybe DeSantis himself
uh who were laboring under the pleasant
delusion that simply being an extremely
competent and right thinking politician
was enough of an advertisement to the
American people and to the Republican
Party
um it's not right and so there's there
is this big issue about you know how
he's presenting himself how he's getting
his message across
um in a weird way my dream scenario
um which is in some ways the most
distant scenario is for us to have a
presidential fight between Ron DeSantis
and Gavin Newsom um and and not because
Gavin has my heart in any respect at all
but just because that would actually
represent the fight that we are having
at the national level a lot of this
other stuff is distraction to me um and
a key point about drawing back uh taking
a deep breath is that leaving aside you
know the moment when we will all have to
choose which candidate we vote for in
the primaries and then ultimately in the
general
um it is a bad idea for us as
conservatives to start slitting one
another's throats this early it's
already going to be a bit of a bloodbath
I think this fight between these two
camps
um you've seen some really nasty stuff
emerging into Nissan Warfare
um and I just don't think it's it's
worth it because the truth of the matter
is although this is a very important
presidential election what's more
important is the energy of the new right
and DeSantis has genuinely been a major
figure a major leader in that part of
the conservative movement he will remain
that way I hope sincerely that he bucks
up his campaign
um it would be a delight to see him run
on his record in Florida if what he was
saying is I'm going to turn the whole
country into this essentially these are
going to be my issues and compare that
to the apocalyptic hellscape run by
Lizard Man Gavin Newsom all of that
sounds like a great message to me um but
it's sounding stiff and wooden and it's
not really it it it seems to be relying
uh alas on competency and and skill
which is actually unfortunately not
enough